welcome back if you enjoy gift giving as
much as I do then you know there's
something magical in choosing the
perfect gift for your loved ones and by
the way if you're a procrastinator then
I relate to you too but I really do love
giving presents we've teamed up with
Amazon and joining us is their director
of toys and games please welcome an
Carill thank you so much for having me
this is just so wonderful many of us
like will have to get our holiday
shopping done for those of you like me
who burn till the last minute um I feel
like now that you're here we're covered
so like welcome to the Amazon toys
Winter Wonderland cuz it's right
here this is incredible right I
know
look oh my gosh this is so exciting will
you take us through some of of like the
hot items this season there is so much
trending it is an incredible year in
toys so Amazon is the destination for
Holiday toys saving money is top of mind
and for the past 7 years an independent
study has shown we've got the lowest
online prices across us retailers
including in categories like toys we
actually have 12 million toys in our toy
store 12 million yes can you fathom that
when it comes to Amazon I can totally we
got the iconic Brands small businesses
unique finds this looks like a very
special toy though yeah so we're going
to kick things off with Radio Flyer is
my first Tesla we're going big we're
going big toddlers need this I need this
so I I feel like I could still slightly
fit on that my personal
favorite it beeps it's fast you can
scoot around you can bump into stuff
it's very durable do they plug it in no
just with your little feet oh oh it no
no engine it just scoots Fred Flintstone
pick it up and run exactly exog that all
right what's next okay this is the
habachi grill set I love this so much
this my daughter would freak out for th
this is the best thing when you go to
the Habachi
restaurant is the onion volcano so we've
got that look at the little noodles like
it's amazing lots of pieces I have my
eye on this what's next it's the year of
Barbie not sure if you've noticed but
it's Barbie's year the movie is so
phenomenal really it's it's
incredible this is Barbie's 3 in-one
camper it's an Amazon exclusive so it's
a little bit of everything so this truck
just sort of comes out of the camper so
four Barbies can scoot around there's a
pool there's a pool sorry did you see
the boat a shower did you did you see
the toilet the H the there's a toilet
oh because Barbie has to go sometimes
everybody does
oh and then I noticed there's Ken and
the ramp and that Ken is in a wheelchair
and I think that's the incredible thing
with Barbie and Ken is they reflect the
world around us just like this I love
this okay this is
fantastic Adventure right here I love it
I love it okay next okay what's next an
come on over well speaking of iconic yes
Barbie and Canen meet Elmo meet Elmo
this is the Elmo slide he will teach you
to do the slide in English or Spanish so
we're just going to give him a
little look at the little
hiple he's so cute oh my gosh I didn't
think I was like going to melt so much
I'm like it's Elmo it's a toy and all of
a sudden I'm like Oh my go I know he's
so cute well I mean this is a fantastic
display oh you have my favorite I love
all of this I mean this is really really
joyful where can we see the full list do
you go to Amazon yes just visit
amazon.com toys to see Amazon's toy list
okay and that should lead to happy
shopping thank gosh for Amazon all right
well thank you for these fantastic
directional toy ideas um but really I'm
so grateful to Amazon for this
announcement everyone in our audience is
going to go home with the Amazon holiday
kids gift book to help you finish your
shopping but that's not all you each are
going home with a
$200 Amazon gift card
and that way you can look at all this
stuff and then go home and execute it
courtesy of Amazon thank you so much for
this than
for am thank you so
[Music]
much